ذلك كشفت كاتلين هيكس نائبه وزير الدفاع
الامريكي عن اسباب طلب الزياده في الانفاق
الدفاعي بالموازنات الخاصه بالبنتاجون
للسنه الماليه لعام 2024
وقالت هيكس ان الطلبه الزياده يهدف الى
مواجهه التحديات التي تطرحها الصين
والتصدي لما اسمته تهديد العدوان الروسي
في اوروبا بالاضافه الى ردع تهديدات ايران
وكوريا الشماليه وفق تعبيرها
طلب موازنه عام 2024 يمثل زياده بنسبه
ثلاثه فاصلتين في المئه على العام الجاري
و13.4% اكثر من السنه الماليه للسنه
الماضيه الرئيس بايدن يعمل على زياده خط
وزاره الدفاع بنحو 100 مليار دولار لبناء
مزيج من القدرات بهدف مواجهه التحدي الذي
تطرحه الصين ومواجهه تهديد العدوان الروسي
في اوروبا وردع التهديدات القديمه من
ايران وكوريا الشماليه والمنظمات
الارهابيه العالميه